it's great to be joined today by Igor
Volsky who's the co-founder and
executive director of guns down America
and author of the book guns down how to
defeat the NRA and build a safer future
with fewer guns
Igor thanks for joining me to talk about
this thank you so much for having me so
to start with one of the things I've
been talking about when it comes to gun
safety regulations is that on the one
hand you have extremely both sort of
fetishized and emotional reactions to
the issue of gun safety from a
significant portion of the population
but at the same time in a lot of places
people are not voting on the basis of
gun safety proposals from candidates so
there's this kind of strange dichotomy
where on the one hand people have
extremely strong views on this issue on
the other hand it's not clear that it's
a voting issue and it leads to I believe
those who are advocating for increased
gun safety regulations at a fundamental
disadvantage do you agree with my sort
of structural framing or disagree
well David one of the most interesting
things I learned when writing guns down
was this new research that analyzed how
the NRA communicated to its members and
what it discovered is that the NRA uses
very emotional terms terms that suggest
a certain identity and so gun ownership
for a lot of the NRA followers or some
portion of the NRA followers isn't just
about the intricacies of policies it's
literally tied in and intertwined with
their identities of who they are
and and the NRA typically describes gun
owners as these good law-abiding
entirely patriotic citizens and of
course describes the other side of this
issue as the folks who want to take guns
away and get government into your life
and it's that kind of frame that they've
been using really since 1977 in a big
way that creates that kind of emotional
connection
and that creates as you point out a
clear connection between the hardcore
NRA members and then how they vote on
this issue so they vote on guns in a way
that the other side doesn't now that's
changing on the gun control side but
it's gonna take some time and of course
the gun control side our side
I'd say talks about this issue in facts
and figures and in all of these wonky
ways that really doesn't resonate as
well as the emotional identity terms
that the NRA uses so I think that's a
big part of why we see that kind of
divide so think back to after the Sandy
Hook shooting there was I mean in a
sense the gun safety advocates more or
less did a lot of the right things there
was a horrible mass shooting there was a
sort of coalescing of opinion that it's
time to at minimum past universal
background checks on any gun transaction
doesn't matter if it's private at a gun
show you just a hundred percent there
was 85 to 90% of agreement on that from
Americans which means that that's that's
some Democrats and some Republicans and
some independents it crosses party lines
and still it wasn't done who and and
when did the failure who failed and why
did that fail to take place even when it
seemed as though the conversation was
going in the right direction
people were relatively United on that
issue what went wrong well look that was
certainly a major disappointment I
remember the day the vote ultimately
failed we were in a restaurant with
survivors who worked so hard to try to
get it across the finish line but in
terms of what actually happened it's an
interesting story because initially
after Newtown there was this real sense
even among Republicans that now with 20
children gunned down six staff members
gunned down in Newtown that something
was actually going to change and you had
Republican members of Congress
particularly in the Senate saying all
right I think I can support this
you had at the very beginning the NRA at
the table helping right what eventually
became the manchin-toomey bill as that
was happening that of course is the bill
that ultimately failed as that was
happening as the manchin-toomey bill was
being put together by senators joe
Manchin and Pat Toomey a Republican and
the Democrats was a bipartisan effort
the gun owners of America which is a
even more conservative gun rights group
than the NRA got wind of the fact that
the NRA was helping put together this
measure and began making a lot of noise
and saying the NRA isn't the real
organization that's protecting your gun
rights it's us gun owners of America and
the NRA never wanting to be outflanked
told back in the entire effort crumbled
and it partly crumbled because of the
pull that the NRA has with Republican
members of Congress to whom it gives
thousands of dollars in contributions
and and who had helps elect and so
that's the dynamic that occurred it
surprised a lot of people that we were
so close to possibly getting something
done there was a true bipartisan effort
and then it crumbled given the internal
politics in the gun rights movement well
it's not even just just the internal
politics because the internal politics
would matter less if in general the gun
lobby had less influence less money and
and less power so what do we do about
that because the geo a versus NRA
dispute is relevant only if as a
lobbying group they have power so I feel
like it's a more systemic problem that
we're dealing with well it is a more
systemic problem but I'll also say that
the gun control movement has really
evolved from where they were in Newtown
to where they are today after Parkland
to a place where you have organizations
like mine guns down America that are
calling for far bolder solutions
to reduce gun deaths that's arguing that
what we really need to do to solve this
problem is to create a future with fewer
guns a future where guns are
significantly harder to get we're
arguing that it's not a problem of the
bad guys having guns but it's the guns
themselves that are the problem and we
need to change the environment for
everybody in which the the environment
in which guns are purchased that needs
to be strengthened the standard for gun
ownership needs to increase that's a big
evolution from where we were in 2013
when the background check bill failed
and it's a real maturity I think in the
gun control movement and it's a change
in dynamic and so I think moving forward
particularly when you saw after parkland
all of those companies I think was about
40 companies that broke ties with the
NRA yeah we just launched a campaign
this morning in the New York Times
that's gonna push the largest public
facing banks to stop doing business with
the gun industry until that industry is
fundamentally reformed that's a new area
of advocacy that seeks to drain the gun
industry seeks to drain the NRA that did
not exist in Newtown so I'm actually
fairly optimistic I mean I take your
point about the dynamics but I think the
movement is so much stronger today in
2019 than it was in 2013 so let's talk
about some let's drill into like one
nitty gritty element of this that I
think the gun safety crowd is not always
completely united on not because of
anything other than it's a complex issue
which is let's talk about types of
firearms okay we know that as a few data
points on the one hand a lot of the more
publicized mass shootings involve what
are called assault style rifles we know
that statistically most gun homicides
are actually handguns in situations
where one or two people are either
injured or killed then there is the
counter to that which is yes but a lot
of those are suicides and it's not
actually people going out and harming
others what do you recommend
then you outlined this new second
amendment compact which we can sort of
talk about in cut this context what is
your suggestion as to what the gun
safety advocate position should be on
types of firearms well first David let
me say you keep on saying gun safety I
would suggest the term gun control
because guns are inherently dangerous
really in anyone's hands which is why
I'm suggesting we increase the standard
for gun ownership
I want to control guns now I find a way
to make those guns safer well I think
it's about when I say gun safety I mean
make make the country safer that's fair
that's fair in terms of what I want to
see and the new second amendment compact
you know they're I think 13 in the in
the final version different policies
that I put forward but it's really
easier to break them up into three
different buckets and all of those
buckets I'll say point towards a single
long-term goal of building a future with
fewer guns and and they look like this
and they go after by the way as you
point out the homicides the suicides
than the mass shootings so bucket number
one is really regulating the gun
industry in a real way right now the
products that they produce are entirely
unregulated
and what happened was in the late 1980s
and early 90s the gun industry made a
decision to begin producing militarized
weapons for the civilian market that's
how you got the assault weapons but just
as importantly that's how you got
militarized handguns that use larger
rounds those rounds are coming at you
faster and what we're seeing in some
cities across America is that folks are
dying from bullet wounds that they were
surviving with past generations of guns
that's a big problem that needs to
change and the reason why they're exempt
by the way is because of an amendment
that the late John Dingell put forward
now his wife who holds his seat wants to
plug that hole she has legislate
to do that that's a good idea so that's
bucket number one really cracking down
on the industry it also of course
includes repealing placa which is that
law that gives broad immunity to into
two to the gun manufacturers and to
dealers bucket two focuses on making
guns significantly harder to get that's
where I talked about raising the bar for
gun ownership and what I mean by that is
if you choose to own a gun you should
have to go to your local police
department get fingerprinted pass a
written test pass a field test pass a
comprehensive background check get
insurance on the firearm you're gonna
purchase have a waiting period between
when you apply for the license and then
when you get the license and then only
then can you get a gun and the old side
then have to register that gun
now there's a system in Massachusetts
that's very similar to what I'm
describing I was going to mention that
here in Boston if I want a firearm I
actually have to go and meet with the
police and demonstrate to their
satisfaction that I have a particular
particular need for its Otis yeah and
that's been a terrific model not just in
terms of lowering homicides but you also
point to suicides right that's two
thirds of our gun deaths we know from
research that people commit suicides
during a short window of crisis and so
getting
extending the length of time between
when you want a gun and when you
purchase a gun get some out of that
crisis window and saves lives yeah of
course people will say that some of
those people who are truly committed to
taking their life at that time if
there's a waiting period they'll find
some other mechanism to take their life
and of course with some people that will
be true but not everybody not everybody
and you are going to save some people
yeah I mean you know there's a little
literature literature on suicide is very
very rich and and statistically speaking
folks who try to commit suicide once and
are unsuccessful are in a period of
crisis when they're thinking of
committing suicide they are far less
likely to try again so yes some people
or determined will of course find
another way but what we also know is
that the suicide by gun is far more
fatal than suicide by any other means
combined so the numbers on that are on
that are very very strong and then the
third piece the third bucket really
deals with some of the gun violence we
have in places like Chicago and
Baltimore in Philadelphia what we have
in those cities are very specific areas
and very specific individuals that you
could literally circle on a map and
figure out where they are street by
street block by block and those folks
are responsible for the overwhelming
majority of the gun deaths that are
happening in those cities and since
about the 1990s what we've had are
community based violence intervention
programs that are operating in all of in
many of these cities that use folks from
the community to help identify who these
individuals are and to de-escalate the
you know the beefs that they might have
away from guns and into and channel that
into more constructive forms of problem
solving and really changing the norms of
the community and that has been
incredibly successful we've seen success
rates of about thirty to seventy percent
of reducing gun deaths in urban areas
those programs are important and they
really need to be supported with federal
dollars the book is guns down how to
defeat the NRA and build a safer future
with fewer guns we've been speaking with
the book's author Igor Volsky who's also
the co-founder and executive director of
guns down America
Igor thanks so much for talking to us
about this today thanks so much David